j'ai appelé à ce qu'on ait une
initiative commune qui permette ça peut
être un appel ça peut être une marche ça
peut être un rassemblement et ça peut
être à Paris ça peut être aussi dans
toutes les régions de France simplement
pour un moment marquer notre refus
définitif sans réserve d'antisémitisme
et que toute la classe politique soit
amenée à prendre position et j'ai donc
demandé à ce que toutes les formations
politique est ce geste- là en précisant
en précisant s'agissant puisque c'est là
où vous vle m'emmené en précisant
s'agissant du rassembléement National
que cela suppose qu'il rompe avec sa
propre histoire et avec un certain
nombre de ses dirigeants militants
cadres qui sont eux-mêmes marqués par
une histoire qui est lié à
l'antisémitisme il n'a pas fallu 4 He
pour que en fait Jordane Bardella
malheureusement apporte la démonstration
que ce parti n'a rompu en rien avec son
histoire en rien avec ce qui a été
autrefois l'objet de sa condamnation
unanime qu'a-t-il dit il a dit
Jean-Marie Le Pen n'était pas antisémite
Jean-Marie Le Pen a été condamné
condamné par la justice à plusieurs
reprises pour négationnisme pour
antisémitisme et avoir aujourd'hui le
patron du rassemblement national qui
vient nous expliquer que non son
prédécesseur n'était pas antisémite ça
montre bien une seule chose c'est que
leur refus l'antisémitisme quand il
s'affiche à la télévision sur les
chaînes de radio et cetera il a un seul
objectif c'est d'instrumentaliser cette
cause pour en faire en fait un coup de
bouttoir contre le monde musulman contre
et et mais il dit aussi qu'aujourd'hui
son mouvement est irréprochable ce sont
non son mouvement ne peut pas être
irréprochable alors même qu'il y a un
parlementaire qui est en fait un ancien
libraire négationniste vous avez y
compris dit que les fait de date de il y
a 30 35 ans et qu'aujourd'hui lui-même
est irréprochable non mais il n'est pas
irréprochable quand vous dites que
Jean-Marie Le Pen n'était pas antisémite
c'est que vous considérez que ces propos
n'étaient pas et pour moi ça n'est pas
un détail c'est effec effectivement la
preuve que ils n'ont pas changé et que
ça est un artifice et qu'ils cherche
simplement à nous endormir à nous
expliquer que en fait l'antisémitisme
est un un mal absolu simplement parce
que en réalité et bien ça sert à taper
sur le monde musulman voilà c'est la se
chose mais j'observe aussi qu'ils n'ont
pas rompu avec toute la galaxie de
l'extrême droite grouusculaire avec les
Identitaires avec les suprémacistes avec
tous ces gens-là et qu'ils ont dans leur
rang des gens qui en permanence sont on
sont issu de ce parcours et donc oui
avec rien du est contenu de cette
déclaration Jordan Bardella vous dites
ce matin que vous ne souhaitez pas que
le RN soit associé à votre initiative
mais la preuve est faite qu'ils ne
peuvent pas qu'ils ne répondent pas aux
conditions que j'avais moi-même fixé qui
est de d'avoir une rupture claire nette
définitive
avec tout ce tous les liens qu'ils ont
pu entretenir avec la sphère antisémite
et la preuve a été donnée
malheureusement hier qu'ils n'ont rompu
avec rien
[Musique]